[Music]
we've had an incredibly long wait for
Final Fantasy 15 but we finally got a
few hours to play the opening chapters
of the game I'm Justin hate Walden I'm
here with Matt Espen le mat you you got
to play through chapter 5 of the game
and I guess that's about 14 hours I I
guess the first thing I want to know is
without going at any spoilers because
you know we've seen a little bit of
what's going on in Final Fantasy 15
through Kings glaive through Brotherhood
the mixed media what are your
impressions of the story so far general
this story I feel I find it very
compelling uh I just but at the same
time I feel like there's this sort of
need to have to watch the other extended
your the Expanded Universe offerings
that the file fast 15 has because
they're there moments where I felt like
they mentioned certain events but the
impact is not really as potent as it
would be as if those if those events
were in the game so it's kind of a
toss-up in some ways it almost feels
like it embraces people who have seen
those those things before but so it
sounds like you've watched them already
yes i have is actually the reason why i
have really into the story to be honest
so just coming at it on its own do you
do you feel like it holds up or do you
feel like it's just better if you see
those other things it holds up okay but
yeah i totally feel like you'll get much
more out of it if you watch the film and
you watch the anime series definitely
and what do you think about the
characters so far because now this is
your first chance to really get in-depth
and play as the game's main characters I
like them a lot they have a very fun
dynamic you know they're definitely a
group of friends who've known each other
for quite some time you know it's really
fun to see them kind of quit with each
other but the same time you could sort
of get a sense of the relationships they
have right you know these are guys who
have been with Prince Noctis ever since
he was young and so when you see them
bond and talk to each other you can
sense that they've known each other for
very long time they're doing this
because they have to but the same time
they do because they they know not
Prince Noctis and they there with him
until the very
sweetu the fruits of one's own labor not
half bad you must be eager to learn more
of a culinary arts actually I'm eager to
leave the cooking to you my half fake
scheme up in smoke so we got a taste of
this with the very first demo for the
game the episode the sky but we haven't
really got a feel for that since then
and that's the thing that makes Final
Fantasy 15 i think more unique is that
it opens with an open world that you're
able to just kind of explore it and do
whatever you want so now having those
opening hours how does that work how do
you feel about that open world aspect I
like it a lot because it it's so
interesting especially when you compare
it to pass Final Fantasy games which you
know of whenever they start they really
take their time trying to develop its
world and really introduce you to the
characters in Final Fantasy 15 it gives
you a cutscene and then right off like
just within the first ten minutes you're
already free to explore the open world I
think that's really distinct compared
the other ones and I like it a lot it's
very different it sounds almost MMO like
yeah totally totally there's just a lot
to do very much like an MMO yeah does it
feel like the side quests and of course
there are there are side quests and
other final fantasy games but when you
have an MMO like structure it feels like
that's a more important thing does it
feel like they're integrated into the
main story does it feel like they're
kind of just separate side things how do
those play into the main game it's a
little mix of both there are times when
you do side quests and it feels like
it's contributing to the main story but
then they're like these instances that
seemed to be the side quests that seemed
to build more on the universe itself
little small things that don't really
seem that crazy impactful to the
conflict but there are they're
interesting diversions that are you know
for the most part I just learn about
taking a little stroll how come you're
all alone you must be hungry yeah I
think the thing people are most curious
about is how the combat is coming
together because we also something we've
gotten a taste of from the demos but now
this is pretty much the final product
this is how combat is going to be in the
main game what are your thoughts on how
it works so far my general patient's of
how it is at this point I like a lot
it's very action influence in the way
that it reminds me of games like they
like crying Bayonetta because you your
character they key can equip up to four
weapons at a time and the whole things
while you're doing a combo you can
actually switch to a different weapon in
the middle of the combo I like this
quality of it and it's definitely
engaging in accelerating to get your
hands on and it's kind of curious I
guess how the magic meter plays into
that because now your magic meter
doesn't really deal with magic it deals
with a combat ability right yeah it's
actually tied to the warplane ability
which is an ability where Noctis can
throw his blade and literally instantly
teleport to the location where its blade
lands you can throw it to an area in the
environment and teleport there you can
even throw it to an enemy and do it
throw into them as well it's a really
cool ability to use but it's different
because of the fact that like that is
the only ability that consumes MP and
you have lots of different weapons that
you got to play around with this time as
well like a really big sword a polearm
what were your thoughts on the different
weapons that you played around each one
felt distinct and that's why we liked
about it because like it really
encourages creativity in combat for
example you can just have like your main
sore and go about just slashing a flow
and then literally you switch to your
heavy sword and just jump and then land
with an instant impact on to the enemy
and cause really getting them out damage
and it's not a final fantasy game
without magic and and I think from the
demo what I got the impression that it
was more like final fantasy eight where
I'm collecting spells and then I kind of
just use them up but it sounds like
that's becoming a little bit more
refined now in the final game yeah it's
something more complex than fontana CA
where you just harness magic and just
use it this time around you harness the
magic but you actually have to craft
them into spells which are tangible real
items that you can equip onto Noctis or
even his friends actually playing on to
the aspect of
being like a real tangible item you
actually have to be mindful of when you
use magic because if you use it while
your friends are just pounding on an
enemy you can accidentally hurt them for
example if you cast like thunder they'll
literally stand there shocked and not do
anything for five seconds so there's a
bit of a risk reward when you're using
that totally tell you have to you
definitely to be mindful of placement
for sure do you have a favorite spell
like the effects that I saw look really
cool yeah totally I loved using the fire
spell because of the fact that it
literally burns everything around even
like grass will kind of just start
burning away also one thing every like
doing the spells is combining the curse
effect onto the fire as well because the
fact of like who doesn't like just
setting an enemy ablaze and also cursing
them while you're at it
I think one of the things that's most
impressive in the game is how could the
food looks it's something we've seen
earlier but now you've gotten a chance
to also play that in the main game and
see how that that affects everything
else does it feel like it's just kind of
a funny side thing that you do does it
feel important to the game itself
although you mentioned that because food
is actually incredibly important because
of the fact that food when you eat it it
gives you special effects for example
like you could eat like an egg and steak
dish and that will give you like you
know like plus 200 HP and plus 30 attack
in the defense so yes you have to be
mindful of what kind of food you eat and
also make sure to eat as much as
possible because it can be incredibly
useful if you're going to take on a
really tough enemy during a sidequest of
some kind
[Music]
so that's just 14 hours of the game we
have a lot more time to spend with it
although one it's for unfortunately not
the full game I can't wait till I get to
dig into the full thing but I'm sure
we're going to learn a lot more about
the game in the coming weeks is more of
a spend time with it if you want to
learn more about what we find out in
this version of Final Fantasy 15 stay
tuned to gamespot com
[Music]